I feel like I'm running in place
Grown man, but I gotta keep a gun on my waist
But OG said don't let that talent go to a waist
Smiling but I did some dog things to get to this cake
In my dog room, just left the club is back to my dog room
With the fiends backing up in this dog room
It's light outside but it felt dog-tune
Hit the lights, cockroaches running on the floor
Can't get no sleep, fiends not get at the door
He could smell the liquor in his pores
And he serving anybody as long as it ain't the law
They threw me in the water, turned to George
It's the middle water, winner, fiend, walk around with George
I smiled but I'm feeling pain, naive shifts in the rain
My nigga took a pill, had a seizure like Lil Wayne
In my dog room, just left the club is back to my dog room
With the fiends backing up in this dog room
It's light outside but it felt dog-tune
Matt Marley in the club, smoking with the sick, got me bad bitch in his bitch
Open off the ribs, pop six bottles
Vowing up the fiends, this is shit we dreamt about
Growing up as kids, although rolly on all because of big
Don't you know we kidnapped kids and thumb off the bridge
The fiends crying over the coke, like it's onions
But standing on a pen is so long, I got bunions
But standing on a pen is so long, it's a massage
But standing on a pen is so long, it's just my job
Well, stay that naze clip, where I learned how to flip
Smoke the skin when I stem, what's burning her lips
Now we here with hard pooms, boats with propellers, crayon
The fiends don't got a dark room, with photos developed
Hey man, in my dark room, just left the club is back to my dark room
With the fiends backin' up in this dark room
It's light outside, but it feel dark to 'em
Time for time, time for time, time for time